welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and multiverse of madness dropped a
big term on us telling us where things
are headed in this next phase of the mcu
and that term of course is pizza ball
because this big pizza ball that we are
living on is about to collide with
several others in an incursion incursion
being the actual new word that we will
be discussing today and thanks to true
bill for sponsoring today's video more
about them later i mean we get the gist
that incursions are two universes
colliding and this all headed toward
battle world and avengers secret wars
overseen by either doom or kang but
really it is the specific way reed
richards in this movie defines the word
incursion how it works how it links with
the darkhold and how this all evokes
some loose threads from loki that we
really need to go deeper into because
when clia shows up to invite strange to
fix an incursion strange who
mysteriously is suddenly okay with
having three eyes i have a feeling that
is not the dark dimension where that
incursion needs to be fixed it's
actually back in 616 and someone in this
scene is not telling us something and
i'm gonna break it all down so when 616
strange meets the illuminati of 838 reed
richards explains steven your arrival
here confuses and destabilizes reality
the larger the footprint you leave
behind the greater the risk of an
incursion stephen asks incursion and
reid says an incursion occurs when the
boundary between two universes erodes
and they collide destroying one or both
entirely this comes directly from the
beginning of the incursion storyline in
the marvel comics starting in 2013 with
john hinkman and steve eppteen's new
avengers vol 1 everything dies t'challa
sees a massive red alternate earth
looming overhead in the sky and he
decides to gather the illuminati a group
he's not totally okay with because he
really hates namor at this point and
reed richards explains essentially what
john krasinski just told us that every
universe is on its own natural path
toward destruction but in the multiverse
there is one universe out there that
meant a premature destruction causing a
contraction ripple effect resulting in
an incursion point at earth where two
earths occupy the same space at the same
time leading to both of these universes
being destroyed or just one of them just
as krasinski said destroying one or both
entirely this comic issue actually
begins with the latin phrase of momento
mooring translating to remember that you
have to die which i always thought could
have been an interesting connection with
the post-credits scene of eternals where
dane whitman finally found the ebony
blade and a container inscribed with
moore's michi lecroom death is my reward
as if this is the kind of warrior that
is waiting for everything to die before
he's activated anyway we learned later
in these comics that that initial event
was caused by doctor doom trying to stop
the beyonders from obliterating the
entire multiverse but in killing one
universe's molecule man triggered that
incursion during this process doom ends
up powering up into a god king status
and creates a patchwork of multiversal
fronts called battle world respawning
heroes from the 616 universe and the
1610 universe in the 2015 secret wars
crossover event and yeah the mcu is
headed in a similar direction especially
now that we know the mcu is labeled 616.
and multiverse of madness showed us what
an incursion looks like on a ground
level the illuminati explains how 838
strange used the dark hole to dreamwalk
into another universe and retell 616
steven quote you never told us the
details of what happened only that you
had inadvertently triggered an incursion
you our friend had caused the
annihilation of another universe later
strange and christine gets stranded in a
post-incursion universe two realities
colliding into each other on the
horizonite universe is a large red
crescent i think that is a victorious
alternate earth depicted as red looming
in the sky just as it is in the comics
now it's not explicitly stated in this
film but this post-encouraging universe
is likely the same universe a38 strange
annihilated sinister strange says i lost
616 strange asks to whom and sinister
strange does not answer he only looks at
616 strange as if to say to you or does
someone like you and annihilating that
sinister strange's universe is likely
the guilt that a38 strange lived with
and why he let his illuminati execute
him now to be clear while it seems like
using the dark hole is what causes the
incursions it's not that simple after
all agatha harkness used the dark hole
for years and didn't cause any
incursions it's specifically using the
dark hole to dreamwalk to force one's
consciousness into a foreign reality
that's why reed said to 616 strange the
larger the footprint you leave behind
the greater the risk of an incursion and
616 strange didn't get there by using
the darkhold you got there via america
chavez's portals so it wasn't just the
dark hole it was the footprint standing
in the wrong reality for too long marvel
head kevin feige recently gave us some
context on how this all fits in with
what we saw in loki loki and sylvie did
something at the end of that series that
sort of allowed all of this to to be
possible he who remains is gone and that
allowed a spell to go wrong in
spider-man no way home which leads to
the entire multiverse going quite mad in
in this and the writer behind both loki
and multiverse madness michael waldron
echoed this saying in an interview the
mcu as we know it earth 616 was
insulated from any multiversal
shenanigans after the events of the loki
finale that protection is gone now if
you're hoping for a multiversal version
of yourself that's better with money
we'll jump through a portal to help you
sort your finances out our friends at
truebill are here to help with a more
realistic solution truebill is an
all-in-one finance platform that helps
you save more and spend less through the
app you can track your expenses manage
subscriptions lower your bills and build
your savings all in one place i really
like how easy truebill makes it to
safely and securely identify recurring
charges and cancel unwanted
subscriptions with just a tap it's also
got some nice credit score monitoring
tools to give you a little nudge when
something unusual might be happening it
won't alert you if a multiversal version
of you is trying to steal your identity
but it will help with lots of other
stuff truebill can also help you create
a custom budget that automatically
monitors your spending by category such
as dining out or entertainment they'll
send you friendly notifications when
you've exceeded your budget and you can
even visualize your spin to earn ratio
in the app get started with true build
today by heading to truebuild.com
new rockstars or by clicking the link in
the video description that's
truebill.com new rockstars so the
conflict between 838 strange and
sinister strange's universes seems like
the opening throws of the multiversal
war insinuated by the kang variant he
who remains in loki the one he warned
would come if he was struck down the
peace between realities
erupted into all-out war each variant
fighting to preserve their
universe and annihilate the others and i
ended i ended the multiversal war you
plunge your blade in my chest and
an infinite amount of me start another
multiversal war and of course this
multiversal war was the one miss minutes
referred to
long ago there was a vast multiversal
war countless unique timelines battled
each other for supremacy nearly
resulting in the total destruction of
whale everything those little sparks
between the timelines is the way this
animation depicts an incursion the
friction between universes colliding now
not to blow your mind too much but time
is a flat circle so it is totally
possible that the past multiversal war
was actually a future multiversal war
for which 838 and sinister strange were
the opening battle of i know i will need
to restock on certain substances before
i can take you down that rabbit hole
either way i would not be surprised if
the next major crossover event in the
marvel cinematic universe isn't called
secret wars even though that is what it
is they may just drop the secrecy all
together and call this avengers
multiverse war now waldron hinted at
this in another interview suggesting
that on the horizon like thanos was in
phase one and two is now a multiversal
threat taking the form of kang or
incursions and this movie's post credit
scene with the three-eyed strange and
clia actually sets us up in an
interesting way that i think we might
have missed strange ends this film with
a third eye and he is screaming he hates
this he doesn't know what's going on we
assume this to be the darkhold's
residual curse maybe even the result of
strangest photographic memory unable to
extract the darkhold pages from his mind
but why then does strange in the
post-credits scene suddenly seem fully
at peace with those three eyes what
changed i think it is possible that the
third eye is actually the latest assault
in this multiversal war sinister strange
last scene with his third eye opening
that consciousness now dreamwalking into
the body of 616 strange giving him that
third eye as he has found a new host in
a new universe to dominate again folks
it's not the dark hole causing the
incursion it is the soul being in the
wrong reality like how clea uses a blade
to tear a rift into this reality the
flaps of that reality bending distorting
it's a sloppy cut one that doesn't look
like it'd be easily patched up it's
honestly a power on par with america
chavez's star portals and she tells
strange that he caused an incursion and
they're gonna fix it and i think that
incursion is not in the dark dimension
that they're headed into the dark
dimension is an abstract dimension
beyond time what would it have to fear
from an incursion between tangible
worlds no the incursion she's referring
to is the one that is now threatening
where they're leaving 616 and this
strange his incursion footprint larger
than ever thanks to sinister strange
embedded in his body with that third eye
this guy is happy to fix it by letting
it burn violence be getting violence as
we slaughter our way toward avengers
multiverse war you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rock stars subscribe to new
rockstar some more announces of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you